no doy por terminado el hecho de las
posibles consecuencias hay una
investigación activa en el condado
fulton estado de georgia por
interferencia electoral en contra del
exmandatario también sabemos de
investigaciones que no tienen que ver
con los eventos del 6 de enero en el
distrito de manhattan en nueva york por
parte del fiscal cyrus vance y
recordemos que todavía está por
confirmarse la nominación de merkel en
como fiscal general de los estados
unidos- ex juez de la corte del circuito
federal del distrito de colombia en una
de las cortes más poderosas antes de la
corte suprema de ser confirmado garland
yo pienso que pudiera existir todavía la
posibilidad de una investigación a nivel
penal de haber participado o incitado la
insurrección o sea que a pesar de el
hecho de que no alcanzaron los 67 votos
en un juicio político que en gran parte
se determinó este este resultado por
motivos
y políticos yo creo que todavía este
tema no ha terminado